die Energiepreise explodieren weiter
Lebensmittel werden immer teurer eine
neue flüchtlingskrise droht Putins Atom
Drogen machen vielen deutschen Angst
doch es gibt gerade in diesen Zeiten
viele Menschen die uns auch Mut machen
die einfach mal machen die organisieren
und die anpacken ja Bild stellt Ihnen
diese Woche diese Menschen vor und für
die gilt besonders eines wir halten
Deutschland zusammen
sie machen Jobs die kaum einer machen
will sie versorgen uns mit dem was wir
benötigen sie verteilen Essen an
Bedürftige sie kümmern sich um
Flüchtlinge
sie halten Deutschland zusammen
[Musik]
Lkw-Fahrer kaum jemand will den Job
machen dabei gehört der Transport von
Waren zu den wichtigsten Pfeilern
unserer Wirtschaft etwa 70 Prozent der
Güter in Deutschland werden per LKW
transportiert mein Name ist Peter
Hartmann ich bin jetzt 61 Jahre alt ja
ich bin Lkw-Fahrer einiges Leidenschaft
ich mag das immer noch gern tun bei
allem Stress sind wir jetzt haben und
uns ist der Situation im Moment ist ist
der absolute Wahnsinn und das schon seit
zehn Jahren
seit 1980 fährt Pete Hagmann LKW früher
so sagt er konnte man gutes Geld
verdienen heute arbeitet man sich kaputt
dürfen nur 48 Stunden die Woche arbeiten
wir arbeiten aber tatsächlich ja ich sag
mal 60 65 70 Stunden geht die Geschichte
hin natürlich wird das nicht bezahlt
weil in Verträgen steht drin gesamte
Kosten oder Unkosten sind damit
abgegolten so und dann muss man
natürlich sehen wie man jetzt wieder rum
kommt also du kannst dich jeden Tag
essen jeder schaffst du einfach nicht
und selbst für die Grundbedürfnisse
reicht es kaum
1700 € netto verdient bithakmann
[Musik]
das heißt also der Bezug findet statt in
dem Moment wo der Fahrer beim B oder
entladen oder in der Wartezeit was ja
auch Arbeitszeit ist genötigt wird ob
Pause zu drücken und damit sind die
Wasserspeicher bei den Speditionen
überhaupt nicht rechtskräftig weil es
wird ja vom Fahrer her also der wird
genötigt das zu machen der Fahrer macht
das schneidet sich aber ins eigene
Fleisch weil danach die tatsächliche
Arbeitszeit und das ist ein Spruch von
der Staatsanwaltschaft nicht
festgestellt werden kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer sich wehrt wird gemobbt und bekommt
Touren die zeitlich nicht machbar sind
das zermürbt
[Musik]
ich wohne hat eine holländischen Grenze
ist seit 30 km sind die Welt anders aus
wird wie in Stunde und 15 16 Euro und
das müssen wir in Deutschland auch
hinkriegen können dass wir überhaupt
unsere Familien versorgen können was wir
im Moment natürlich ganz schön happy ist
und schwierig ist ne
kein Wunder dass Nachwuchs noch sehr
schwer zu finden ist kaum jemand will
den Job mehr machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
trotz Fachkräftemangel blieben im Jahr
2021 gut 63.000 Ausbildungsplätze
unbesetzt besonders betroffen die
klempnerbranche dort blieben
38,9% der Stellen frei
[Musik]
ja mein Name ist Mike Menke ich komme
aus Paderborn ich bin Sachverständiger
für Abwassertechnik und verantwortlich
für ein abwasserunternehmen mit
sanitärdienstleistung wir haben hier ein
riesen Super-GAU gerade gerade im
regionalen Handwerk denn die
Lieferketten funktionieren nicht mehr es
kommt kein Material nach die Regale sind
leer wie man hier im Hintergrund sieht
und dazu kommt noch das teilweise
europaweit ausgeschrieben wird meine
Forderung ist hier natürlich auch an die
regionale Politik hier Aufträge heimisch
zu vergeben und hier auch den heimischen
Handwerkern den Rücken zu stärken und
hier nicht eben auch auf den günstigsten
Preis zu gucken bei Ausschreibung
sondern hier fordere ich ein ganz klares
Zeichen auch für Kleinstbetriebe und im
Mittelstand dass die heimische Politik
hier auch die regionalen Handwerker
unterstützt
[Musik]
Handwerksmeister Mike Menke arbeitet
seit 19 Jahren als
Gas-Wasser-Installateur er beschäftigt
19 Mitarbeiter und fünf Azubis
auch diesen Job will kaum jemand mehr
machen Flüchtlingen helfen doch
angesichts der drohnenflüchtlingswelle
werden Menschen wie Janine persigel aus
Auerbach im Vogtland in Sachsen dringend
gebraucht mein Name ist Janine persikel
und ich arbeite seit 15 Jahren in der
Stadtverwaltung Auerbach im Bereich
Soziales und habe natürlich mit allen
Lebenslagen sozusagen zu tun im Bereich
Soziales jetzt natürlich auch mit der
ganzen
flüchtlingsthematik wir haben in
Auerbach ca um die 200 Flüchtlinge
derzeit und haben für die bestmöglich
versucht alles zu organisieren rundherum
bezüglich der Energiekrise natürlich
auch in Auerbach so dass jetzt viele
Leute nicht nur sag ich mal die
Flüchtlinge auch die Bürger der Stadt
Auerbach
Probleme bekommen ihren Lebensraum zu
sichern aber wir merken es natürlich
ganz stark dass die antragswelle für
Wohngeld für Sozialhilfe viel größer
wird allgemein im ganzen Stadtgebiet für
alle Auerbacher
das sind Deutschlands zusammenhalter und
so kämpfen sie mit gegen Krise
Kriminalität und Missachtung
[Musik]